each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello good afternoon it's my pleasure to
introduce Luhan who is a PhD candidate
at Texas A&M is supposed to go away
maybe this June maybe in december are
you sure but he's done his job and he's
going to give two talks today because he
was here as an intern this past summer
so this first talk is actually the work
he did when he was over here and the
second is more related to this thesis
talk so good we can try to put them
together just really two separate things
this one all right thanks everybody for
coming so the first talk that's a zero
overhead online verification of software
programs as daniel said that was my
intern project last summer so here's a
list of things I'm the cover first for
motivation I'm the dress some issues
with the traditional see assertion based
online verification practices and then
our proposed solution is p SL plus image
where PSL stands for property
specification language emails that's
extensible MIPS processor after that I'm
the go over some more details about our
zero overhead online verification
framework at last experiments and
conclusions so in general software
verification is the act of checking the
conformance between software
implementation and specification online
verification is one way to do software
application is based on executing and
executing a targeted program and the
checks its online behavior at the wrong
time so see assertion is a widely used
online verification practice it's
basically a macro name desert with a
boolean type expression as argument
here's a simple example the function
takes two in
your pointers and swaps their value the
assertion at the top of this function
checks if the two input pointers p and q
are now or not or and make sure they're
not equal let me make sure they do not
point to the same memory location so
while the assertion is widely used I'd
have certain issues so the first one we
see is execution overhead so for C
assertions to be a functional they have
to be linked into the target of software
and executed as a part of as a part of
the software so take CPU cycles and it's
going to slow down the target software
inevitably so later only this talk I
will show that the overhead can be
removed by using image the extensible me
profit processor another issue with C
assertion is its limited expressiveness
essentially see assertion is based on
propositional logic so but oftentimes we
want to describe the temporal properties
of a software program but the assertions
is not designed for that purpose so for
example it's easy to specify with a
serious ershon that want to say a
pointer should not be now at a certain
point of a program but it's it's very
awkward if not impossible to specify
that a pointer should never be now
during the entire lifetime of a program
or a function so the other issue with
the assertion is that it lacks a clearly
defined a notion of time therefore is
not suitable for describing real-time
properties we're going to argue that
these issues can be soft by using a more
expensive x
pressive specification language called
psl property specification language psl
it's a Hydra buoy standard property
specification language it contains the
linear time logic which is a
well-established temporal logic as a
subset of the language psal can express
many interesting temporal properties
which I should give some examples in the
next slide originally psl is it's
designed to specify hardware requirement
but in my project it is adapted for C
software specification and in fact it is
also good for other block structure the
programming languages such as our I'll
go or you know Pascal as well here's a
few example psl properties the first one
it says the invocation of the function
Emma log should always be followed by a
invocation of free sometime in the
future that's performing memory checking
the second one is a real-time property
it says that the interrupts should never
be disabled for more than 10 millisecond
and a third one detects stack smashing
based attacking basically what it says
is that the return address of a function
on the calling stag should never be
overwritten by malicious code here's a
few more properties that can be handled
by our online verification framework
regarding memory checking and
multi-threaded program arrow detecting
for example the use of uninitialized the
memories how the boundary memory
accesses so these are all very so her
not frequently encountered bugs in the
software program
other examples such as detecting data
races in the multi-threaded program and
so on and so forth so in the next couple
of slides I show I'll give a bit more
details about the property specification
psl here's its syntax a psl property is
a expression of atomic propositions
connected by psl operators there are two
kinds of operators a standard set of
boolean operators and temporal operators
including always eventually until next
and etc atomic proposition here is just
a sea assertion in these case the
pointer P should not is not now
semantics the semantics of psl property
is defined with regard to the execution
traces of a sea program or a safe
function so a program or function
satisfies a psl property p if every
possible execution trace satisfies p an
execution trace here is defined as a
sequence of observations where each
observation where each observation is a
realization of atomic propositions so
here's a example property basically what
it says is that your request should
always be followed by a acknowledgement
in two time units and here's an example
execution trace so if we look at the
three observations in that in that red
box in the first observation req equals
one indicating that a request has been
made but in the following two
observations no acknowledgement is
observed so both both of them is AK is
zero
so that indicates that these property is
violated by this particular execution
trace right it's kind of tedious to
legally rigorously define the semantics
of the PSL language but fortunately
oftentimes a the PSL of expression is
fairly intuitive we can just look at it
and guess what it means so I'm not going
to define every aspect of a psl language
so how do we check a psl property
against a an execution trace there are
two ways first first the offline checker
it's kind of a record first and then
check afterwards approach basically what
it does is that it stores the entire
execution trace in the first row of the
table and then it checks each sub
property against each sub trays and
store the result in a subsequent rows of
that table until in the last row it
finds it it computes a checking result
of the original property again so the
whole execution chase so the main issue
with this offline based approach is that
it takes it needs to store the entire
execution trace therefore it takes a
indefinite amount of memory the other
approach is an online approach which is
based on a finite state machine so in in
the next two slides I'm going to talk
about online checking more details but
conceptually what it does is that the
finite state machine called verification
state machine is driven by the
observations each time it gets a new
observation it moves the fine
the machine to a new state and there are
two special states in this finite state
machine corresponding to satisfied and
violated respectively whenever the
finite state machine moves to either one
of these two states the checking is
completed and no further observation
needs to be processed so this basic idea
of online psl checking is that to check
if an execution trace starting with
observation 01 satisfies the PSL
property p one only needs to check if
the rest of the trace satisfies a new
property reduce the from of the original
property P and the first observation 01
this step is called a property rewriting
step if after one or more property
rewriting step the original property P
reduces to a boolean expression true
that means the property is satisfied by
the execution trace otherwise if P
reduces to false then that means
property P is violated now here's an
example so again recall that the the
meaning of this property is that a
request has to be followed by
acknowledgement in to time of units so
you want to check if this property P
holds for a particular execution trace
we don't know that trace yet but we do
know that this trace starts with the
first observation 10 indicating that
request this one acknowledgement is 0 so
by the semantics of this property P we
have received a request which means that
the rest of the execution trace must
satisfy two things first acknowledgement
has to be received in two time units and
the second p also needs to hold for the
rest of the execution trace
according to the semantics of the
operator hallways so that is to say the
rest of the execution trace has to
satisfy p and q now if in the second
observation ACK is still 0 then that
means in the third observation
acknowledgement has to be received in
order for the property P to hold for the
original execution trace and again p
needs also to be p also needs to hold
for the rest of the restitution trace
again by the semantics of always now if
in the third observation ACK is still 0
we can safely conclude at this point
according to the semantics of that
property that the property has been
violated by this execution trace no
matter what observation is observed in
the future so it turns out that these
term rewriting process can be
implemented as a finite state machine so
here's a verification here's how the
verification state machine looks like
for the property we've just looked at
and the term rewriting process in the
previous slide actually correspond to
one pass in the verification state
machine so this verification state
machine based online checking approach
it doesn't need to store the execution
trace it consumes a fixed amount of
memory and in addition to that it is
synchronous meaning that it can detect
any violation and earliest possible
moment that's it for psl now
I'd like to address the other issue of
the execution over had the issue with
the traditional see assertions and as I
said the proposed a solution approach is
using an extensible MIPS processor this
is this is the architecture so like a
traditional MIPS processor it has a five
stage a pipeline the register file the
memory interface and the coprocessor 0
so these are compared these components
collectively are referred to as teaser
the trusted instruction set architecture
but in addition to Tisa image has two
extra functional blocks here and they're
called extensions extensions can stall
the pipeline perform memory load and
store thrown exceptions and execute
complex logics it can also passively
watch the pipeline as well image has
been used in successfully used in many
interesting applications including mips
assembly code acceleration on cheaper
peripherals hardware support for
software debugging and online software
verification in my case in our case so
here's a this slide shows how the c code
of the of a program and its psl
verification is processed on the email
platform the sea source code is compiled
by GCC into the executable and executed
by the main pipeline the PSL
specification for the sea program
however is compiled by our p2v compiler
into Verilog code first and then enter
the beat found later so the beat file is
loaded into one of the extension
of the MIPS processor as a monitoring
unit for the main pipeline what it does
is that it transparently it passively
observed the execution of the targeted
program on the main pipeline collect all
the information and the performance
online checking so although all the
monitoring unit says is numerical values
or addresses it understand what's what
the see program is doing such as what
the variable is the program is writing
or reading or what functions the program
is calling because it can extract that
information from the debug information
generated by GCC basically GCC generates
a sort of a symbol table that tells us
what's a virtual address of function
what's what's the offset of a local
variable relative to the stack pointer
and stuff like that that information is
used by the monitoring unit to figure
out the behavior of a sea program let's
do mean the monitoring unit it consists
of two component the observation you
need oh you and the verification you
need vu so the observation unit its main
task is to generate the execution trace
by memory snooping and the registers
moving from the trans from the tisa the
trustee the instruction set architecture
the verification unit it implements the
verification state machine I mentioned
before it inputs the execution trace
generated by the observation unit and
outputs two signals satisfying and
violated so both of these two units are
a specific meaning that we are
automatically generated by the p2v
compiler the observation unit its main
task as i said is trace generation which
consists of two subtasks scope detection
and atomic proposition evaluation
although the circuit of observation unit
varies from property to property but
they all share some common building
blocks as shown in this slide each each
a building block is a parameterised a
very long module implementing a basic
functionality of a observation unit for
example the stat as a scope detector
what it does is that detects the entry
and exit of a function corresponding to
the start and end of an execution trace
it has three parameters the virtual
address of that function the frame size
of that function and the prologue size
of that function again this information
can be extracted by the debug
information or the symbol table
generated by the GCC compiler other
high-level building blocks include
global tracker local charter argument
the tracker so the other functionalities
are you know keep tracking of the values
of a global or a logo or art or argument
of a function so at the top at the
bottom are two lower level building
blocks registers nuber and the memories
nuber what they do is that they are the
watches all the right transactions to
the memory file to to the register file
sorry and in memory and it maintains a
valley the local copy of all the
relevance of variables that
needed for that's needed for atomic
proposition evaluation so here's the
circuit for the atomic proposition P is
not now from the previous swap example
so to generate this circuit p2v compiler
first figures that in the knees a
comparator to perform the comparison
operation then one of the young argument
of these comparator is the value of the
function argument function argument p so
it generates a argument attractor here
other than that so the the the argument
tracker needs a parameter 10 which is
the offset of this argument p relative
to the frame pointer and again this
information can be extracted from the
symbol table generated by GCC so in
addition to that it figures that it
needs a frame pointer tracker to keep
track of what's the current what's
address of the current frame pointer on
the calling stack and which in addition
needs a registered Snooper which keeps
track of what's a current value of the
stack pointer SP so at last p2v
assembles all these four building blocks
into the circuit of this atomic
proposition P is not now
so say if we don't take this approach we
take the traditional see assertion
approach then then the assertion p is
not now will be compiled into a small
sequence of meats and instructions shown
here and to evaluate this assertion p is
not now these a sequence of the MIPS
instructions needs to be executed by the
traditional mid CPU they are certain
overhand associated with it such as
instruction fetching decoding data
fetching and etc but if we use the
special purpose hardware automatically
generated by P to V then of these
overheads are gone
so the other component of the monitoring
unit is a verification unit to generate
the verification unit for this psl
property what p2v compiler does is that
it analyzes this property computes it
computes its verification state machine
and translate this verification state
machine into the Verilog code
description the translation from here to
there is actually fairly straightforward
the Verilog code is basically a big case
statement where each case corresponds to
one transition in the verification state
machine
okay so i've argued that the image by
using extensions of the ellipse
processor to implement the monitoring
unit we can remove the execution
overhead of Thea surgeons but we do need
to spend some of the hardware so the DB
extensions are implemented as on fpga
chip so to achieve the zero overhead
monitoring we do need to spend some FPGA
area to implement the hardware logic of
the verification up tia of the
monitoring unit and so in the in the
next two slides i will show how much
logic we need to implement for different
kinds of psl properties we measure the
fpga chip area 40 overhead monitors and
the experiments are done on a xilinx
fpga chip with the is a development
toolkit the area the area cost is
measured in terms of number of xilinx
fpga slices which is a basic resource
unit of the fda chip the first
experiment will measure the area cost
for implementing n stack smashing
detectors here's the experiment result
as a graph indicates the the Ariel Casso
grows linearly with the number of
detectors with a lower end xilinx fpga
chip model LX 25 we were able to fit
around 30 detectors on the chip and the
higher-end lx200 we are able to fit
two hundred detectors so most of the
areas are spending for implementing the
observation unit the error calls for are
the observation unit versus the
verification unit is around to 10 verses
3 and most of the area are spent for
implementing 32 32-bit registers
multiplexers comparators and such
now here's the second experiment in this
experiment I will measure the area costs
for implementing the monitor of this
particular real-time property basically
what it says is that in the next at any
of the next n time unit a must hold in
additional in a another ten time unit
and the same for be in this exhibit
experiment the observation unit only
watches a two variable a and the B
that's taking a small in a constant
amount of area so the area costs mainly
comes from implementing the verification
unit and according to a capacity
analysis that didn't cover in this talk
in the worst case the verification unit
could take double exponential space
which is fairly bad but I will show our
experiment shows that in practice this
worst-case scenario doesn't really
happen this is the experiment result
which shows that the area cost grows
with the timing constant n and the
growth follows a nonlinear pattern but
the growth is significantly closed
slower than the worst-case double
exponential scenario for timing constant
n equals 2 13 will the the error cost is
about 1400 slices which is around one
third of the Alex 25 chip so when we
when we try to perform experiment on
bigger ends I mean Pierre the chip
actually has more area for bigger ends
will try to experiment with
that but the xilinx synthesized tools
isn't just so great it runs out of
memory and kind of crashes right here's
a brief summary of this work I've
briefly described at P the PSAL + MIPS
based online verification framework this
is first zero overhead online software
verification framework it can handle
general purpose as well as real-time
software properties it detects abnormal
behavior at the earliest point of time
and again I didn't cover this but we've
able to get a tighter upper bound on the
size of the verification state machines
which isn't known previously that's
pretty much all can I answer any
questions where the assertion expression
would require a certain amount of memory
so in other words it not just looking at
at boolean checking but saying you
wanted to make sure that that a sub I
does not equal a sub I plus 1 where
listings come in at different different
times in the code I'm not sure I get
that well so if you have let's say you
have a large array a million bikes or
whatever and the and the assertion
insurance for second checking is that
that a sub I does not equal a sub I plus
1000 ok so you don't have access to both
both of those values at once you
probably have one of them because you
just computed it that's why you're
checking the assertion did you do
anything with that with that kind of
assertion so there's certain limitations
20 overhead online monitoring experience
so basically what kind of risk
restrictions we put into our approach is
that the data we want to monitoring its
address has to be computable in advance
meaning that if we're talking about
array indexing or you know pointers
those kind of things expect a kind of
dynamic behavior and say for example I
think I have a one slide right here say
for example we want to check if the
dereference the value of pointer P is
less than five since you can modify the
value of the pointer P at any time and
when you execute the program so if
there's no way for you to know the value
of star p in advance so in this way the
there is certain overhead associated
with checking this expression basically
the monitor has to stall the pipeline
fetch the value of pointer to pointer
type IP from the memory and venue
Valerie to the assertion is that kind of
what you're asking yeah but that's right
but let's a fundamental image it's it
does not only apply to our approach I
think it applies to every online
verification approach which tries to
achieve the zero overhead yeah I guess
it would be acceptable to do that right
i mean yeah he if you have to do a
memory access you have to do a memory
access right right do the do the
extensions have any services right the
extensions does it would be done yeah it
could be done definitely the questions
ok how much better if the how much
better about well I was feeling said
that was financial and that thing was
even simply as financial right um so so
basically any psl properties can be
rewritten to a property with only these
few operators not or and the next day
operator which I didn't cover but
doesn't really matter so suppose these
intervals are the the timing parameters
of the real time for real-time
properties this is going to be the worst
case scenario of the size of the
verification state machine so you can
see it's a double exponential expression
where you know j 1 j 2 j up to GN could
be any number and integer number and
we're we're able to show that this upper
bound can be improved to this new one so
in terms of I 1 I 2 I n which is a
leftist left side of those timing
intervals j j 1 j 2 j n is that the
right side of the time intervals in
terms of i 1 i 2 up to IM this
expression is still double exponential
but we were able to move those bigger
numbers j 1 j 2 j and from here to here
right so that's
that that actually significantly
improves the the upper bound that we are
looking at it before like give a rough
sense to men
okay so if there are no more questions I
show
it's a good part of my talk which is in
quite a related to the first part but
anyway so topic of this talk is a range
search in distributed sensor networks
the list of things I'm the cover in this
talk first I shall give a little bit
background about its distributed sensor
networks and then I will present the
problem these are this work is trying to
solve which is a range search problem
and then i shall present three
algorithms with progressively more
general retrieval past functions after
that the optimality result and
conclusions so first distributed sensor
networks a sensor network consists of a
collection of sensor node which each one
is equipped with certain sensing
communication and processing
capabilities typically the sensor node
is a small embedded devices with with a
limited energy and a memory and the
communicate through each other through
short-range radios what that means is
that a sensor can only communicate with
nearby node and a faraway knows they
communicate through each other with
multiple hops so in older generation of
sensor networks there's typically a base
station which is kind of a central a
point for data storage and retrieval but
in this talk the talk the subject of
these targets distributed sensor
networks so there's no central base
station the network works in more of a
peer-to-peer fashion all the sensor
networks are deployed in 2d or 3d
euclidean space so usually there is a
very strong correlation between the
sensor network topology and the geometry
the networks have been used for habitat
monitoring target tracking foul
detection and many other applications a
Jill geographic routing is one of the
popular routing techniques for sensor
networks it's it exploits the topology
and the geometry correlation of sensor
network basically how it works is that
it uses Euclidean coordinate as an old
address and employs a combination of
greedy routing and and face traversal
based routing for dense sensor networks
the route consists of a sequence of
roughly equal ends hops so as shown here
and the routing cost is spent is
measured by the energy consumption to
deliver one unit packet from the source
to the destination if the network is
relatively dense then the cost is a
roughly the number of hops in that path
which is in turn roughly the Euclidean
difference of the source to destination
distance this talk is about the range
search problem basically a range search
a range curing asks for all the data
items in the region or some statistics
about the data items in a region in
these case the user sitting at a node q
asks for the average temperature in the
remote region denoted by that blue
circle the oftentimes in sensor network
applications the users care more about
local information sort of rather than
remote information and in this talk I
shall focus on this local range search
problem
depending on where sends a store and
retrieve the data there are many many
ways to attack whole the range search
problem here's just too straightforward
solutions so first a sensor can choose
to store the data locally and in this
case to retrieve the range information
and no it has to flood every sensor node
in the region that's called a scope of
the flooding the other straightforward
way is for sensors to broadcast its data
to everybody else in the network so in
this case everybody in the sensor
network knows everybody else's data and
to answer a range Curie it can just
retrieve all the relevant information
from the local storage and does not need
to can be communicated with anybody else
at all we want to look at too kind of
costs associated with this range search
process the first one is storage costs
so as I said a sensor can choose to
store a copy of the data at multiple
nodes in the sensor network and the
storage costs of a node is defined as a
number of copies for its data stored at
other sensor node the second cost is a
retrieval cost as defined as the amount
of energy that a sensor which is
required to answer a range Curie there
is a fundamental trade-off between the
storage and retrieval costs so for
example for the first solution the
storage cost is only one and only stores
one local copy but the retrieval cost is
kind of high it's roughly of the order
of r square where r is a curing range
due to the flooding
but for the second approach the storage
cost is really high his stores is copy
everywhere so the storage cost is n
where n is not is a total number of
sensors in the network but the retrieval
cost is very small it's virtually zero
there's no overhead associated with it
it's because of this trade-off there are
obviously many other solutions out there
and in the next couple of slides I shall
show three other solutions which
achieves different kinds of trade-offs
between storage and retrieval and by the
way this is this is a fundamental
trade-off it also applies to other
sensor network applications such as
object tracking information brokerage
and and etc instead of directly working
with a advanced sensor network makin
simplification we work with a regular
agreed agreed is a widely used network
model for sensor network research so to
understand that we can sort of use a
grid instead of a den sensor network we
can think of this way for each sensor
node in the original den sensor network
we can solve the sort of a map the note
to the closest the grid point in this
grid Network right and since since the
original sensor network stands the the
mapping only causes a small error in
various applications a key concept in
the design of the sense of local search
algorithm is that of D lattice so node
is a deal at is node if both of eggs
and y coordinates are integer multiples
of the quantity d all the sensor all the
nodes in this in the grid are one
lattice nodes and here's a set of two
lattice nodes set of four life is not
the other important the concept is that
Abby neighbor it is defined as the four
corners of the deal and a square a
particular node is located again for
example here the four green nodes are
under 44 neighbors of the purple node so
with the concept that the lattice and
the neighbor we can start to design the
three algorithms and mentioned just now
here's an overview the retrieval cost of
the first two algorithms are a linear
function of the curie range are here and
the storage cause of the first two
algorithms are upper bounded by a log
function of the network diameter d the
first and two algorithms are similar but
the difference is that in the second
algorithm it allows the user to specify
the constant in the linear function here
could be an arbitrary constant compared
with that the third algorithm allows the
user to specify an arbitrary retrieval
function f of r and then it tries to
optimize a storage cost for the users
requirement so in this sense the three
algorithms they are they have
progressively more general retrieval
functions
so here's the first algorithm on the
left side is a storage strategy of this
algorithm basically what it says is that
each sensor stores its data at its 42
the 22 the ice neighbors where I ranges
from 0 1 up to log D in other words a
note here stores its data and all these
red nodes since that's four copies at
each level and there are log D levels
the total storage cost for this strategy
is order log D on the left on the right
side is it is retrievable strategy to
retrieve the range our information an
old q retrieves from it node q goes to
is 42 to the ceiling of log our
neighbors where are the retrieval where
r is the radius of these are retrieval
range the reason that node q can
retrieve the data of all the nodes in
this circle I just go into this for for
a nose is because according to according
to the retrieval strategy r is less than
or equal to 2 to the ceiling of log r
which means that the yellows of the blue
circle is completely covered by the nine
squares and according to the storage
policy any node in the nine squares has
to store at least one copy at at least
one of the four corners of the center
square
which means that any node in the blue
circle has to store at least one copy at
one of the four nodes right here and
therefore by visiting these four nodes
node q can retrieve all the information
in that blue circle and according to the
retrieval strategy the cost of this
retrieval strategy is of order to to the
ceiling of log R which is of the order
of log R and a more careful analysis
shows that the constant in this
expression is 8.82 basically it's the
first algorithm the because the quantity
8.82 here is called a stretch factor of
the retrieval strategy the second
algorithm is just a little bit more
involved than the first algorithm it
says no the stores is data at two to the
I lattice node within distance d sub I
where the expression of that d sub I is
given it here it's a storage policy you
retrieve the range or information an old
q goes to its 22 the JS neighbors we're
JS expression is as follows so again why
why a node q can retrieve all the
information in this range by just going
to this four nodes and this is because
let let P be an arbitrary node whose
distance to q is less than or equal to r
by plugging the expression of j into the
expression of d we can we can know that
the distance of P and Q must be less
than or equal to D
J that means Q must be located in these
black circle of note p and according to
the storage of policy p stores a copy of
its data at every one of its two to the
JS lattice node within the black circle
so which means that P must have stored a
copy of this data at at least one of the
four cues to tjs neighbors according to
the expression of d there are a constant
a number of red nodes in each black
circle and they are according to this
expression again there are of all their
log D circles so the storage cost for
each node in this strategy in these
algorithm is of order log R and
according to the revo strategy it is it
it is easy to verify that the retrieval
cost of node q which is which is equal
to the lens of this pass is bounded by s
times are where s is an arbitrary
stretch factor which can be specified by
the user
so the basic design principle of
algorithm to is to use the power of two
lattice nodes as a places for data
storage and retrieval it achieves the
linear retrieval and the cost of
logarithm storage in the elbows in three
I'm the present in the next slide is a
generalization of the secondary
algorithm the basic idea is to use a
different hierarchy of lattices for data
storage and retrieval and it can achieve
a retrieval function retrieval cost
function f of r which could be in
arbitrary which could be an arbitrary
monotonically increasing function so
here's how the 30 hours and works so
each sensor stores this data at all the
L I else of I lattice nodes within
distance d sub I and retrieve the range
our information an old cue goes to is LJ
neighbors where j is biggest integer
satisfying that inequality here's the
illustration so the third day hours
looks almost identical as a second
algorithm except that in the second
algorithm else I in a DC by are both
exponential sequences but in the third
algorithm in this one it is given as a
solution of this optimization program so
I'm not going to get into more details
of this optimization program but
basically the objective function is the
storage costs it measures the number of
retinoids in each circle and the
inequality in the dread in the blue sir
in the blue box guarantees that a node
can retrieve all the information within
range are
at the cost at the retrieval cost of at
most f of r is a nonlinear optimization
program and in our experiment we use
MATLAB to start this program so both
algorithm two and three this poor the
linear retrieval cause the function f 0
f of r so one question we asked to our
selves is that which one performs better
in the linear retrieval case and the
question can be answered by is inserted
by a sequence of experiment which is
conducted on my laptop with a pending m
one point three gigahertz CPU 1 gig of
ram and matlab 7 so in the experiment I
compared the storage costs for algorithm
to and algorithms three using different
combinations of two parameters the first
parameter is a stretch factor as the
second one is network diameter D and
here's a result in the first group of
experiment a set of the stretch factor
to be two and a changes the network
diameter and in the second group of
experiment the network diameter is fixed
and a change the stretch factor as in
all the experiment the storage costs of
the third algorithm is less than the
storage cause of the second algorithm as
the table shows so here's a kind of
numerical result of of the performance
of the of these algorithms the other
question we ask ourselves is that so
both algorithm 1 and a 2 uses logarithm
storage
to achieve a linear retrieval cost so it
is this trade of a optimal trade-off or
if if it's not then there any better
designs it turns out that we can prove
logarithm storage is asymptotically
optimal for linear retrieval for a wide
class of networks called growth boundary
networks a network is called a growth
bound in the network if so here's a
technical definition if any sphere of
radius R in this network contains at
least r over r prime to the RFS spheres
of radius R prime where r and r offer
could be two arbitrary number and the
constant alpha here is called the growth
rate and the grid network is a special
growth boundary network with great are
with rage too so with the concept of
gray a growth boundary network we can
prove these optimality result and the
proof technique is called spheres with
exponentially decreasing radius it's a
is a little bit more involved and here's
only approved sketch so there's this one
fact about growth boundary network which
says for any sphere s and any retrieval
past p starting from the sender of s
there's a big enough sphere contained
inside as such that p couldn't touch
more specifically if the lens of this
retrieval past p is bounded by a
constant the stretch vector as times R
where R the radius of these
sphere as then we can show that there
must exist this is fear as Prime whose
radius R prime set such that our prime
equals to V of s times R where Z of S is
a is a function of only the stretch
vector as if we consider the stretch
vector as it's a constant and then this
quantity is a constant so it's like we
can shrink this bigger sphere into a
proportionately smaller a sphere such
that the retrieval costs cannot touch
this small sphere and the proof of the
optimality result is basically a
sequence of application of this
particular effect so starting from a
sphere as one and it's fear of s1 and a
retrieval costs p 1 starting from the
center of s1 apply this fact that we can
find a sphere as to such that p 1 cannot
touch as to and at the same time the the
size of the radius of s2 is only a
constantly a constant factor of the
radius of s1 what that means is that
everybody in this smaller sphere as 2
has to make a copy at some note on this
retrieval called p1 in order for v1 to
retrieve all the information in this
range are one with a with the linear
which we will cost
so if we apply the same argument to s2
we can find another sphere as three
right here such that all the nodes in
the s3 has to make a copy on the
retrieval pass p 2 as well as a
retrieval pass p 1 and the radius of s3
is again a constant factor of the radius
of s2 and if we repeat these process and
if you assume that if we set the the
fear and the outermost to be of radius D
over to where D is the diameter of the
network then in log these steps we can
get a sphere at the innermost of this
whole sequence such that the center of
the center of the innermost the sphere
has to make a copy every one of the
retrieval past p1 p2 p3 p4 and so on and
so forth so these know the sitting at
the center of the innermost sphere has
to make at least a log B copies of its
data in order for in order for everybody
to be able to retrieve the range or
information with linear costs so that's
that's that's briefly how this proof
works
and here's a brief summary so I
discussed the local range search problem
for distributed sensor networks proposed
a algorithm with general retrieval cost
function which is first time that's
that's achieved and I showed that and
the logarithm storage is asymptotically
optimal for linear retrieval and the
results both of the results also apply
to other sensor networking applications
such target tracking information
brokerage and etc and that's it for this
talk I ask any questions
so how much can you generalize this
going to generalize this to any store
and forward and a program to a store and
forward Network yeah you set the right
right so so in this slideshow so I argue
that the result can be generalized to
other applications such as target
tracking information storage and in fact
one application I didn't mention is a
compact the routing so the compact
routing problem tries to achieve the
mostest the least a stretch routing
tries to strip as achieve the routing
with the minimum stretch with with with
a minimum routing table so the storage
here is a routing table and the
retrieval cost is a routing pass so
there's a similar trade-off in the
combat routing problem as well but at
this point I'm not sure if the approach
i presented here can be applied to that
scenario as well I'm not sure yet but I
hope there's hope there yeah you divided
it sparse the front like the local
problem when the provel problem what is
your considerations did you envision
where the remote probably maybe more
thing more just redo the whole problem
that really depends on the application
well say since this since sensor
networks are almost always geometric
networks if if you can see their states
say if you're in a zoom you want to
sightsee all the animals you use a
sensor network to keep track of the
location of every
animals typically when you are at a
certain point in the zoo you want to see
what's around myself what what animals
are can I can I see within you know walk
distance so that's that's that's the
reason that local local research is it's
preferable in many sensor networking
applications and remote load then remote
range search but but yeah if if your
application really requires remote local
remote and registered to then there's a
different story the linear routing from
the relegation to your location in the
additional storage for seeing the
information through the network right
that's one way to do that so for example
if the user here is really interested in
the information in the remote region
what it can do is that it can go you can
first go from q2 the center of this
remote region and then issue a local
range search so that's like edition of
the to cost amazing
well fact be to be sore the overlay
networks right as one clear that one
will be cashing like a kakaka my kind of
problems they also fall in the same
category right they're similar so p2p an
edge work there is something called a
locality aware or distance insensitive
p2p searching so what it means is that
if you're talking about a p2p protocol
such as cord or can it allows you to
retrieve a piece of data with a
relatively small storage costs but it
doesn't guarantee that it does not
guarantee locality awareness what it
means is that say I want a copy of a
video there are many copies out of the
word on the internet by using a distance
insensitive p2p search technique even
though there is a copy of this video in
Seattle I might end up traveling all the
way to you know to Texas or to Mexico to
find a copy which is far away from from
myself but there are many proposals
research proposals for distances
sensitive or locality aware p2p search
which guarantees that if there is a
nearby copy of the data you can find it
and also you can find it with the cost
that's that's that's a linear function
of the distance between yourself and the
copy of that file it can also be
generalized to a general function rather
than a linear function by applying this
technique right let's p2p thing so what
the other thing you
the caching thing right I'm not sure
what that is but sounds like that sucks
has a similar problem will you put your
passion such that if you where here you
have to give a distribution suppose you
can choose to this mission you use this
sort of algorithm to come up we'll put
this additional actions I haven't tried
that in practice but yeah that's uh
that's something very interesting i can
i might want to try in the future
right I'm gonna brush to us that would
be good